where is that
where is it
where is it
where is that goddamn it where is it
where is it oh yeah
now we can begin the box
Swedish boy goes to America are you
gonna read that long time oh my god yes
okay so Berto Bo we decided that we're
gonna do it a challenge so who can wear
this stupid shirt so does everybody have
the same way everyone has the same one
me Brad and Michael Venegas
well they have to wear the shirt I'll
explain more the rules later but all you
need to know is that if I I'm caught not
wearing this shirt I get a strike what
happens that day right
I'll explain later I told you she says
what's my shoe you today there's no way
you didn't take it talent tell me where
it is she took she took my running shoes
this morning and I was looking forever
and now she took my other shoes okay
fine I'm going out like this
right sorry this is the most annoying
[ __ ] to walk with one shoe
she said under the bed oh my god there
it is
no it said only nice things why did you
hide my shoe you know you just started
raining girl la never rains
I say how how is this happening
gobbles do something man I look like
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] with this outfit
I just realized 21 days oh boy we just
arrived to LA today or last night and
I'm so jet-lagged and I feel like [ __ ]
as always so I'm excited for the vlogs
okay so we're going grocery shopping I
feel like I'm gonna get shot wearing
this I don't know does it mean anything
else here I feel like all the American
vloggers
cuz they always long in the grocery
store I'm going to put the people spray
cheese I'm already grossed out yeah
Jesus Christ how big do you need
[ __ ] crazy the sizes I never seen
them this pic cheesefest here we go
12 years single malt
it's empty
so I have a setup while I'm in LA racer
hooked me up
Thank You razor love you guys so much
is this a razor deck buy this oh that
looks nice that looks very nice oh whoa
Dan that looks sick
that looks prettier than mine what the
[ __ ] what is all this is it liquid
cooling it all works beautiful thank you
so much racer for hooking me up
I was worried not having my setup when
I'm away but this is [ __ ] awesome
held to the yeah yeah I got a better
vlogging camera that's definitely not a
vlogging camera it's a very nice camera
the quality is amazing so I'm really
excited to try and use it let's let's
hook it up
oh oh oh oh no I pack the wrong bag this
is the wrong bag
god [ __ ] damn it I don't believe it I
don't have that any of the SD cards and
I can buy them but I bought like a lot
of them well this is the setup supposed
to have a tripod I can't show you now
cuz I don't have an SD card god damnit
I wonder if this microphone works with
that this phone this is the current
situation oh my god yes no I found this
SD cards I don't know if you hear me in
the camera vlogging I'm probably way too
close because I don't have the tripod
that's pretty good I bet everyone's
gonna be like I preferred a dish
cellphone blogging camera yeah well I
spend a lot of money on this camera see
you better you better like it are you
[ __ ] insane
if Brad and Michael isn't wearing them
I'm going to be seriously pissed oh my
god Brad is not wearing a show me that
Brad is not raining the Swedish shirt
yeah you get your strike Brad we'll see
we'll see what he has to say later I
just got a text message from Gobbo and
he's told me that Brad is live-streaming
but he's not wearing the shirt that's
two flags Fred thank you gobble
thank you gobble so brad has two strikes
[ __ ] yeah
this makes me so happy first day two
strikes I'm making meatballs tonight
we're doing this Swedish theme it's the
only dish I know it okay we have five
bags but no handles and we have to walk
back we're skirt
you like my idea okay
[Music]
you made it my arms Oh me and gobble is
just gonna chill for an hour and then
I'm going to start cooking because Brad
Emma and Michael are coming over
tomorrow is the first day of scare
PewDiePie shoot and I'm a little nervous
going through all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
again episode 1 will be shot on
Halloween it's Halloween guys time to
cook me boss we got traditional
meatballs and then we got [ __ ]
meatballs Wow
for my skin there's a vegetarian this is
the meatball the base of the meatball
and this is a giant ass onion how do you
make them so big America with the what
do you put in your onions scare
PewDiePie they make sure you don't touch
my fake meat with your
yeah oh you started the challenge
without some [ __ ] you were a boy like
that you have to be strikes you [ __ ]
[ __ ] nice you're sure this was the
stall do I just get strike you have to
be fast
yeah great you have three we check your
Instagram your twitch I was watching you
yeah I wore this shirt all day what are
you stupid why wear the shirt Oh
Michael is here is he wearing your shirt
you can't see the flag to honor the flag
what just wear sweater over it no I will
skip a strike you both my friends always
get a good shot why are you shocked it's
blue and we're told the gang
there were Caucasian beer blue how dare
you wear that speech bag you haven't
right is going to try the Scandinavian
July it's something called Scandinavian
July which is fruit-flavored and going
with a meatball how dare you whoa weird
you should try my own meatballs and this
cannon even delight I mean it's good
there's nothing to reactor you don't
like it you're wrong
how is this Scandinavian me feel oh the
meatballs is good I think
[Music]
Wow well okay well first of all three
because you're not wearing the shirt
well we instruct the video hey you
cheated and it's crazy
there's 21 more days over turbo we have
to wear the shirt in every shot if you
see us not wearing the shirt we get a
strike brad has four strikes how does
that feel
clap it up for Brad everyone good job
Brad you came up with this idea yeah you
see this thing we're filming right now
the agreement was that we put the shirts
on in this shot for the first time and
they both conspired you have four
strikes that's all they have fired
against me to show up okay why don't you
tell them what happens if you do the
more strikes the one that with the most
strikes after 21 days after 21 days has
to go to a cheat tattoo parlor and get
an American flag tattoo your wedding
yeah so basically you're gonna cheat so
much you're gonna work together against
me that I have to get tattooed that's
already what's happening so yeah yeah my
first one shouldn't be this one yeah
that's right I think if you get more
than a certain amount US for air strikes
we get to pick where we'll win tattoo no
yeah okay well that's burnable for you
get out of here shoosh Varna bow episode
1 I hope you guys enjoyed it was weird
to be back logging but I think I think
it's fun anyway
I'll see you tomorrow with another
episode first day shooting scare food
run as always
[Music]